[موسيقى]
ما ان تقع اعيننا على الفوانيس وزينه
الشوارع حتى نشعر بقدوم رمضان اجواء
اعتدنا عليها منذ الصغر
[موسيقى]
واليوم وبعدما غزت التكنولوجيا والعالم
الرقمي معظم نواحي حياتنا كيف غيرت في
اجواء رمضان ماذا اضافت وماذا اخذت
التكنولوجيا حساها خدت حاجه من رمضان ولا
اديته خدت كل شيء من رمضان
خدت اولا لمه العيله ما فيش دلوقتي حد
بيتلم
ماسكين الموبايلات 24 ساعه مش اليوم
قاعدين على الموبايلات قاعدين يعملوا ما
فيش حاجه التلفزيون ده اتلغى بقت حاجه
قديمه بعد الابلكيشنز الكتيره اللي بقت
موجوده ما بقاش اصلا محتاجين للمسحراتي
ولا لمواقيت الصلاه ولا اي حاجه احنا ما
بقيناش نتبع اي حاجه خالص كل واحد ماسك
الموبايل وانا قاعد انا وحفيدي لا لا لا
لا ده التكنولوجيا دمرت
العلاقات الاسريه
[موسيقى]
اجواء رمضان ولكن بنكهه حديثه هكذا نشعر
نحن ولكن ماذا عن الاجيال الجديده التي
ولدت ونشات في هذا العصر مش شايف ان هي
اخذت منه كتير بالعكس هي هي مساعدات نحن
على الاقل بنعيد على بعض اكتر
ممكن بدل ما نتكلم مثلا قرايبنا او كده
اللي هو ننزل خلاص نبعث لهم مثلا على
الواتساب حاجه اللي هو كل سنه وانت طيب
صور فوانيس والفيديوهات والكلام دوت يعني
حاجه حلوه برده بتاعه رمضان وكده
[موسيقى]